So let's summarize the differences
between message passing and
shared memory.
Regarding who does communication
in message passing, the programmer
is responsible for figuring out who
sends and who receives the data.
In shared memory,
though communication is happening
through shared variables in memory, so
all of the actual sending of the data
back and forth is fully automatic.
The programmer doesn't need to do that,
they just store to memory and
load from memory, and it is the
responsibility of the system to figure
out when the data gets sent and to whom.
As far as data distribution is
concerned, that is, which cores
get to have which data in their memory,
the programmer needs to manually do this
data distribution, by explicitly sending
the data to the cores that need it.
In shared memory,
the system is responsible for
sending the data wherever it's needed,
so the programmer simply loads or
stores to the data, and it's the job
of this hardware and the software of
the system to figure out which data
should be local where at what time.
As far as how much hardware
support we need for
message passing,
this support is relatively simple.
We just need to basically have
a network card and a network.
It can be a very fancy network,
but it's just a network.
In contrast for shared memory,
we need extensive hardware support
that automatically figures out
when to send data, and to whom and
where to cache in, etc., etc.
So we will be spending a large portion
of the rest of this course on just
figuring out what this hardware
support needs to look like.
So as far as the programmer
is concerned, the programmer
worries about two things, correctness
and the performance of their program.
They want their program
to be correct and
do as well as possible
on the available cores.
In message passing,
getting correctness is difficult,
because you have to orchestrate
everything perfectly and you can get
all sorts of data log issues, and
wrong distribution, etc., etc.
In shared memory,
correctness is also not easy to get, but
it's less difficult than
with message passing.
Performance with message passing
is difficult to get, but
once you get correctness,
performance is not far away.
In contrast, shared memory,
performance is very difficult to get and
the difference between correctness and
performance can be large.
So it might be relatively easy to
get a program to be correct, but
it's performance might not
be anywhere near good, and
then it might take a lot more effort
to get it to also perform well.
So with message passing somehow,
by solving the correctness problem,
you are also solving a large
part of the performance problem.
In shared memory, it's easier to
get things right, but the effort
to get it to perform well might be
even more than with message passing.